Optimal like this altitude.
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
Books.
I've loved on the Tim Ferriss show is exclusively brought to you by audible.
There couldn't be a better sponsor for this series.
My dear listeners and readers I've used audible for so many years,
as long as I can remember. I love it.
Audible has the largest selection of audio books on the planet.
I listen when I'm taking walks. I listen while I'm cooking.
I listen whenever I can. And if you're looking for a place to start,
I can recommend three of my favorites.
The first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite letters of all time touches on stoic philosophy,
calmness under duress, et cetera.
The next is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
G a I M a N one of my favorites,
even if you're a nonfiction purist,
this is the fiction book that you need to listen to.
Neo also has perhaps the most calming voice of all time and third,
Greg McKeown's essential ism subtitle.
The disciplined pursuit of less.
This is one of my favorite books of the past few years combines very well with
the 80 20 principle, but more on audible every month.
Audible members get one credit for any audio book on the site,
plus a choice of multiple audible originals from a rotating selection.
They also get access to daily news digests from the likes of the New York times
wall street journal and the Washington post as well as guided meditation
programs. And here are some other amazing audible features.
And I use a bunch of these. You can download titles and listen offline anytime,
anywhere I use this feature,
even when I could get access, I'll put my phone on say airplane mode,
because I don't want to get bothered with notifications.
And I'm taking a walk to clear my head and you can listen to titles offline in a
case like that or on a plane or whatever.
Obviously I'm not flying much these days.
The app is free and can be installed on all smartphones and tablets.
You can listen across devices without losing your spot.
And whisper sync is another feature I use quite a lot.
I love reading my Kindle in bed. For instance,
then picking up at the same exact spot where I left off.
When I go walking and listening to the next day,
Kindle and audio versions can be sinked up automatically is just amazing.
And if you can't decide what to listen to, don't sweat it.
You don't have to rush.
You can keep your credits for up to a year and use them for instance,
to binge on a whole series. If you like audible offers just about everything.
Podcasts, guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, alias comedy,
and audible originals. You won't find anywhere else.
And right now audible is offering you guys.
That's Tim Ferriss show listeners a free audio book with a 30 day
membership. And, uh, again, my list, if you want to check them out,
the Tao of Seneca, the graveyard book, essential ism,
those are just three there's so many good ones out there.
Just go to audible.com/tim and browse the unmatched
selection of audio programs. Then download your free title and start listening.
It's that easy? Just check it out.
Go to audible.com/tim or text Tim T I M
to 500, 500 to get started today. Check it out.
audible.com/tim.
Hello, boys and girls, ladies and germs. This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show,
where it is usually my job to sit down with world class performers of all
different types, startup founders, investors, chess champions, Olympic athletes,
you name it to tease out that habits that you can apply in your own lives.
This episode, however,
is an experiment and part of a short form series that I'm doing simply called
books. I've loved. I've invited some amazing past guests,
close friends and new faces to share their favorite books.
Describe their favorite books. The books that have influenced them,
changed them, transform them for the better.
And I hope you pick up one or two new mentors in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own life.
I had a lot of fun putting this together,
inviting these people to participate and have learned so, so much myself.
I hope that is also the case for you. Please enjoy.
Hi Tim Ferriss listeners. It's Whitney Cummings. Uh,
thank you so much for letting me do this, Tim. Um, I'm only picking two books,
uh, because I just wanted to keep it kind of short and sweet.
The first one that I wanted to suggest is a book by Gavin de Becker.
It's called the gift of fear, survival signals that protect us. Um,
it's a lot about, you know, stockers and violence and stuff like that,
but there's, um,
a lot of invaluable advice around hiring people and
drawing boundaries with people, vetting people, um,
for people that want to be highly productive for people that want to have their
weekends off for people who want to have a drama free workplace for people who
don't want to spend their time and emotional energy on difficult
people. This is a,
this is a pretty transformative book in terms of
learning how to trust your gut and not dismiss red flags or write
them off. You know, um,
I spent a lot of time working with people that were exhausting,
egomaniacs, difficult people,
people who would be kind of a time suck in terms of managing their emotions or,
you know, people that interpreted constructive criticism as rejection.
And then I felt like I had to take care of their feelings and,
and this and that. I mean, for someone that has those feelings,
I also recommend Melanie Beatty's book, um, codependent no more.
And the adult child of alcoholics, big book, ACA big book. Um,
but if you've done that work and you know,
you're not being codependent in turns out,
someone's just being really difficult.
And this book is pretty wonderful for not dismissing your own gut instincts
because a lot of times when someone's difficult, you want to go, well,
I'm probably just being sensitive or I probably was too harsh,
or I probably should have handled it this way,
or I shouldn't have sent an email that was that direct when you start blaming
yourself, um, there's a something I want to read to you.
Uh, so I can start getting more specific on one 23,
page one 23 of the gift of fear he writes.
If you tell someone 10 times that you don't want to talk to him,
you are talking to him nine more times than you wanted to.
If you call him back after he leaves 20 messages,
you simply teach him the cost of getting a call back is 20 messages.
I love that because I don't think I understood that setting a
boundary. Isn't always saying boundary, it's setting a boundary for yourself.
You know, if someone doesn't respect your boundary,
you don't just keep setting the boundary.
You just have to completely disengage with the person.
If they don't have the emotional intelligence acumen or the ability to,
to read a situation in a way that's appropriate.
And it took me a long time to stop engaging in inappropriate behavior at the
workplace. For me, if some, if it was like,
I just have to spend an hour every day with this person to get them to act the
way I want them to that's an hour more a day than I need to be spending with
this person.
So this book really helped me understand that sometimes the only way to win is
to not play. Um, you know,
sometimes the best strategy is a masterful retreat when it comes to crazy
people that are just not able to take a hint. Um,
so I highly recommend digging into that, uh, chapter.
There's a great story about this, uh,
person who is at a workplace who was becoming a problem. And, um,
I highly recommend that I also earmarked, uh,
page one 58 for some reason. And Oh yes, I did. It's about, um,
references, uh, when you're working with people getting references, you know,
I've made a lot of hiring mistakes because I tend to hire people because we get
along really well.
We have really good chemistry or like this person's so funny or, you know,
we're both from DC or, you know,
like we've all had those things where we want to hire someone that we actually
should have just been friends with instead of someone we should actually be
working with, you know, eight hours a day in high stakes situations. Um,
I've made this mistake before I used to never ask around about people.
I used to never get references. I used to never call, like,
you'd see references on resume. You'd be like, Oh,
well obviously if are numbers there that counts that's easy enough. I think,
you know, I like to now spend way more time hiring. Uh,
it helps me save time later in, in drama, frankly.
So on one 58,
the failure to take the obvious step of calling references is an epidemic in
America.
And I have little patience for managers who complain about employees that didn't
care enough to assess before hiring a common excuse for this failure is the
references will say only good things since the candidate has prepared them for
the call. In fact,
there's a tremendous amount of information to be gained from references in terms
of confirming facts on an application.
Did you know him when he worked for such and such firm,
when did he work for such and such firm?
Do you know roughly what salary he was making?
Do you know what school he went to? You said you went to school with him.
I suggested questions asked of those listed as references,
be guided by information on the application.
The most important thing references can give you are other references.
We call these people, develop sources. These are people who know the applicant,
but whom he did not list as references accordingly,
they are not prepared for your inquiry and will be more likely to provide
valuable information.
You get the names of developed sources by asking the references,
the applicant listed for the names of the people who know him.
I'm reading that now. And for some reason it sounds really hard to understand,
but it basically means as the references for other references.
So the people that weren't necessarily prepared for your call do research before
you hire people the same way you would vet someone, you date someone, you marry,
someone you have in your home, that people that you work with.
It'll save you a lot of time and emotional energy in the long run,
and you will be more prolific,
productive and happy on page two 82.
There's a great section on public speaking. You know,
a lot of people these days, if you're starting a business,
if you want to be a performer, uh, if you want to be an entrepreneur,
you have to be able to speak in public. And I think even now,
if you only want to be a behind the scenes business person, investor, whatever,
you also have to speak at panels, you have to do Ted talks,
you have to do a YouTube channel, you know, public speaking.
Now isn't really optional, um, social media, YouTube.
So there's kind of a great section on that. Um,
and it's a section that's about like rules. Uh,
what you fear is rarely what you think you fear. It's what you linked to fear.
There's a whole section about fear in public speaking,
quote surveys have shown that ranking very close to the fear of death is the
fear of public speaking.
Why would someone feel profound fear deep in his or her stomach about public
speaking,
which is so far from death because it isn't so far from death when we link it.
Those who fear public speaking,
actually fear the loss of identity that attaches to performing badly.
And that is firmly rooted in our survival needs for all social animals from ants
to antelopes.
Identity is the past card to inclusion and inclusion is the key to survival.
If a baby loses its identity as the child of its parents,
a possible outcome is abandonment for human infant. That means death as adults,
without identity, as a member of the tribe or village community or culture,
a likely outcome is banishment and death.
So fear of getting up and addressing 500 people at the annual convention of
professionals in your field is not just the fear of embarrassment.
It's linked to the fear of being perceived as incompetent,
which is linked to the fear of loss of employment, loss of home, loss of family,
your ability to contribute to society, your value in short,
your identity in your life,
linking an unwarranted fear as the ultimate terrible destination that usually
helps alleviate that fear.
Then you may find that public speaking can link to death.
You'll see that that would be a long and unlikely trip. Just a really great,
uh, chapter on fear and, um,
public speaking and sort of how we link things in our brains. And, uh,
that stuff just fascinates me.
And I think is really important for anyone that wants to be, um,
successful quite frankly. Um,
so highly recommend the gift of fear by Gavin de Becker.
The second book I'm going to recommend is a title that I just
hardly can say out loud. It's so embarrassing,
but it is such an incredible book. It is called getting the love.
You want a guide.
For couples? I can't even say it without laughing.
Um, I remember when I first bought this book, I had to do it in person.
It was like kind of before Amazon and I went to Barnes and noble back when that
was a store and I went up to the guy and I was like,
can I get this book it's called getting the love?
Like I had to whisper it in the bookstore. I was so embarrassed to say it.
And then he said it over the loud speaker.
Who's like getting the love you want I'll too. It was very embarrassing,
but the book is so unbelievable.
It's by Harville Hendrix and Helen Kelly Lee hunt. I mean,
Harville Hendrix is really famous for developing a Mago therapy.
And before I read a chapter to you, I think, you know,
I talk about this a lot,
but I think that the relationship you're in is a business decision.
I know most of Tim Ferris's listeners are chiming in for great business advice,
productivity advice,
the person you choose to be your partner is a business decision,
the amount of money that you're, um, you know, saving depends on that person,
the amount of time you're putting in your business depends on that, that choice,
the amount of emotional energy that you have depends on that choice,
the amount of support you get. You know,
I feel very strongly that in order to be, you know,
brave and take risks in your professional life, you have to have a very stable,
safe, supportive, personal life. So I'm a big fan of, um,
anyone that wants to achieve wildly astronomical
goals. Uh,
you have to make sure that your home is in order as well and that your heart is
in order. Um,
I think it's important that anybody that wants to be successful in any part of
their lives understands neurology and neurochemistry.
You guys have heard me blather on about this, um,
on page 45 of getting the love you want,
what causes the rush of good feelings that we all call romantic love.
Scientists who study natural hormones and chemicals tell us that lovers are
literally high on drugs substances that flood their bodies with a sense of
wellbeing during the attraction phase of a relationship,
the brain releases more dopamine and norepinephrine.
Two of the body's neuro-transmitters.
These chemicals help contribute to a rosy outlook on life.
A rapid pulse increased energy, and a sense of heightened perception.
Oxytocin is enhanced as well as a potent hormone.
That plays a role in many aspects of our lives, including childbirth, nursing,
orgasm,
and bonding of mother and child and social connections between individuals,
some refer to it as the love sex hormone during the phase when lovers want to be
together. Every moment of the day,
the brain also ramps up its production of endorphins,
natural narcotics that enhance the sense of security and comfort. Um,
you guys might know this on some level,
but I think it's really important that people understand that, you know,
being in love, being attracted to somebody, being in a new, intense,
passionate relationship, you're literally high on drugs. Uh,
it can be a huge distraction to your work life, um, if it ends up lasting,
that's great, but for the most part I've worked, you know,
a lot of people ask me, uh, how do you do work so hard?
How do you save so much time? I really try to limit the amount of, uh,
in my past, um, rampant love affairs,
because most of it is just neurochemicals.
Not everyone is the one and that's okay. But I think the, um, really intense,
passionate relationships can be a giant distraction, um,
ultimately from the goals that you want to achieve.
So I always think it's important that people really understand, you know,
cause you can meet someone and then lose four months of your life to someone
that you're like, I don't even like that person.
I was just high on neurochemicals. That was a big waste of time.
So I think that, you know, we learn something from every relationship we're in,
but, um,
I see a lot of people's careers suffering because they get distracted
by relationships that ultimately don't yield that much and lessons that
they quite frankly don't need to learn. Um, page 73, uh,
there's a great chapter on the stages of a power struggle in a relationship. Um,
when you and your partner are immersed in a power struggle,
you have a little sense of when it all started or how it will end,
but from an outside perspective, the power struggle has predictable course.
One that parallels the well-documented stages of grief in a bereaved person.
I'm not going to read that whole chapter to you,
but that's a really interesting one. Um, and then on page one 15,
uh,
there's a big chapter on empathizing and being able to see your partner's inner
world to understand, you know,
cause sometimes we say something and it's not received the way we intend it to
be received and we get so confused. How can they not understand we're saying,
because they're seeing it through the lens of their own experience, trauma, uh,
parenting and neurology. So there's a great, uh,
exercise on how to empathize with your partner.
And when you're in a disagreement, you repeat what the other person says.
It's a pretty great exercise. Um, because you know,
how often are we in relationships?
And we say something and the other person completely contorts it and twist it.
And you're like, that's not what I said.
And then you start fighting about fighting. Uh,
you're not even I'm finding about the thing you might be like,
what were you in fighting about? Uh,
so what you do to minimize the amount of time that you're in one of these
altercations or power struggles, um,
if I say I'm uncomfortable that you showed up late and the other person has to
say, I hear that you're uncomfortable that I showed up late, but this,
this and this. And then I have to go, well, I hear that this, this and this,
but you know,
so you have to mirror what the other person says so that you're actually having
a productive conversation that just doesn't turn into, you know, uh,
your childhood circumstances and, and trauma responses clashing, um,
and being a ultimately complete waste of time because I know Tim Ferriss
listeners are very possessive, uh, about their precious time.
Um, this book is a lot how we are attracted to people that have the
negative qualities of our primary caretakers. Um,
I find that to be incredibly important information just to know that that is how
we lean in general, our brains want to, um,
finish unfinished business in our work life and our professional life.
In our friendships.
We tend to be attracted to people who have the negative qualities of our primary
caretaker. So when you're going out on dates, when you're selecting a mate,
when you're selecting friends, when you're hiring employees, uh,
it's important that you understand that that is going to be what we're attracted
to.
And often when we're attracted to the people that have the negative qualities
are our primary caretakers, uh,
it turns into this thing that we've been marketed as being called chemistry.
I have great chemistry with that person,
but it really could just be your inner child going mom is that you
dad does. And then we end up just having our inner child run the show.
And for the most part, um,
the people I end up working with are not the people that I have amazing
chemistry with necessarily. It's the people that hear me when I say something,
uh, have direct, clear communication. Uh,
the people that you work with do not have to be the people you hang out with all
the time and text with all day. Um,
you don't have to be besties with the people you work with. I think, uh, um,
between these two books, it's a really good way to make sort of emotion free,
clear logical hiring, uh, and partnering,
uh, decisions so that you're acting from your brain and not your heart.
And so your inner child's not running the show. So again,
I recommended Melanie Beatty.
Co-dependence no more getting the love you want from Harville Hendrix and the
gift of fear survival signals that protect us by Gavin de Becker.
Hey guys, this is Tim again, just a few more things before you take off.
Number one, this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird that I've somehow dug up in the,
uh, the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared
with my close friends, for instance. And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that, check it out,
just go to four-hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up, I hope you enjoy it.